-It is time for "Tonight Show"
hashtags, everybody.
♪ -Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Hey, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So with the DNC convention
happening right now,
I asked you guys to tweet out
a funny campaign slogan
and tag it with
#mycampaignslogan.
Within five minutes,
it was a trending topic.
So thank you for playing along.
I appreciate it.
Now I thought I'd share some of
my favorite #mycampaignslogan
responses from you guys.
This first one is
from @noseworthyann.
She says, "What happens in 2020
stays in 2020."
Viva Las Vaccine.
This one is from @richierich39.
He says,
"I passed my cognitive test."
Oh, I'll vote for that.
[ Laughter ]
I know elephants and giraffes.
This one is from @danvan03.
He says, "Everyone reaches
that moment when you interrupt
that uncle at the dinner table.
America, this is that moment."
[ Laughter ]
That's a beautiful speech.
This one is from @womack717.
She says, "Let's not find out
if rock bottom has a basement."
[ Laughter ]
I like that, too.
No one wants to know that.
This one is from @mayhemwp.
He says, "Vote for me
and I'll add you
to my 'Selling Sunset'
text chain."
Oh, that's --
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, I'm already busy
with my "Below Deck" chat, so...
Did see what happened to Hannah?
Mm, mm, mm, mm.
[ Laughter ]
This one is from @trulykhayyam.
He says, "You've tried Trump and
Pence. Now try common sense."
[ Laughter ]
That rhymes.
This one is
from @apewillshowers.
-What?
-Yeah, ape will showers.
-Ah.
-So, yeah. Like April showers
but ape -- I don't get it.
It's --
Yeah, I do.
It's April.
It's apewill.
-I thought he was trying
to be cute.
-I think it's just cute, yeah.
Yeah.
-Almost cute.
It would have been cute
if showers was, you know,
ape will show-- "shorwers."
[ Laughter ]
This close.
-What do you mean?
It does say that.
Ape will showers.
It says ape will showers.
-Yeah, but no,
if it said ape will shorwers.
[ Laughter ]
-Shallers?
-That will work too.
[ Laughter ]
-Ape will sh-- hours?
-See it?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
I don't get it.
It's from @apewillshowers.
She says, "America, blink twice
if you need help."
[ Laughter ]
Here's the last one here.
It's from @fherron01.
They say, "Alexa, 2020 off."
Yeah. Please.
[ Laughter ]
There you have it. Those are
our "Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.